- Oh! (laughing)
- I'm from the East Coast,
so I've heard of them,
but I've never had one.
- Who thought, who put this together?
I've got clam juice and tomato juice,
and maggi, and, yeah.
- Was someone, like, drunk, and they were
just like, "Yeah, this
sounds like a good drink."
- Are you serious?
- This is literally,
like, a bad trip to Epcot.
Like going around the world, like...
- But in one drink.
- Yeah, it smells like
a spicy Bloody Mary.
- It smells like a really
drunk person's vomit.
- (both) Cheers!
- How do you say "Cheers!"
en es-pan-yol?
- Salud.
- This is refreshing as (bleep).
- Wow.
- Oh, it's great.
- It tastes like vomit.
- It's kind of like the chola
version of a Bloody Mary.
It's like what you would have when
you don't wanna have, like, vodka.
- If I had a choice between this and
a Bloody Mary, I'm taking this.
- It's, like, a little carbonated,
but not, like, overly.
- I'm going for a second.
- I hate it so much.
- I hate this.
- It feels like a perfect summer drink.
Something that you can have when
it's really, really hot outside.
- Keep my Worcestershire
sauce out, on my steak.
Not in my drink.
- Meanwhile, I love it.
- I'm done with this, I can't
put more of this inside me.
- I feel so bad...that's what she said.
(laughing)